Marvel Studios' Black Panther has brought
King T'Challa and his home country of Wakanda
to life, drawing inspiration from the hundreds
of Black Panther comics.
Virtually every character in the film was
inspired by a comic book counterpart, and
while they might never see the same twists
and turns in the movies that they did in the
comics, there's a lot more to them than you
might've thought.
Here are the characters from Black Panther
who might just have a little more meaning
than you realized.
And in case you haven't seen the movie yet,
spoilers ahead!
Shuri
In the film, Letitia Wright plays Shuri, the
young technologist responsible for the Black
Panther’s vibranium-powered tech.
In the comics, however, her role wasn’t
limited to fighting alongside T’Challa.
In 2009, she actually replaced him.
While Shuri wasn’t introduced until almost
40 years after Black Panther first appeared
in 1966, her rise to prominence came pretty
quickly.
After losing the Black Panther identity twice,
T’Challa decided that he’d be a lot better
off choosing his own successor.
Since Shuri was his closest relative, and
since she’d already proved her valor by
defending Wakanda against an invasion by Klaw,
he chose to train her.
Sure enough, her ascension as Black Panther
later became necessary.
After T’Challa was injured to the point
of death, Shuri took the Heart Shaped Herb
and became the new Black Panther and the ruling
Queen of Wakanda.
Whether or not the movies will follow this
storyline remains to be seen, but as we’ve
already seen her as a capable warrior in battle
and the brains behind the Black Panther’s
tech, we wouldn’t rule it out.
Ulysses Klaue
Despite being the character who links Black
Panther to the earlier installments of the
MCU, Ulysses Klaue, as played by Andy Serkis,
isn’t exactly the major villain of the movie.
Instead, he makes his exit about halfway through,
a red herring that works so well because in
the comics, Klaw is one of Black Panther’s
most enduring arch-enemies.
Like the version in the films, comic book
Klaw was an amoral arms dealer with a keen
interest in vibranium, and even sported the
sonic “arm-cannon” in place of his left
hand.
The big difference, though, is that his abilities
didn’t stop there.
In a desperate attempt to gain super-powers
that would make him the equal of the Fantastic
Four, Klaw transformed himself into a being
made of living soundwaves.
Klaw began a supervillainous career that saw
him battling against the Fantastic Four, Daredevil,
and Black Panther, forming a hatred that would
see him amassing an army of supervillains
to invade Wakanda.
The question is whether the movie version
of Klaue will make a return in a form that’s
closer to his comics counterpart.
As good as Serkis is in the role, and as nice
as it is to see his actual face for once,
you don’t hire the world’s most famous
motion-capture actor if you’re not planning
on turning him into a being made of pure sound.
M’Baku
One of the biggest surprises of Black Panther
came in the form of M’Baku, T’Challa’s
first challenger to the throne of Wakanda.
Played by Winston Duke, M’Baku is the leader
of the Jabari Tribe, who have withdrawn to
Wakanda’s mountains, where they live without
dependence on vibranium.
His towering physical presence and sense of
humor make him one of the movie’s most memorable
characters.
But given his comic book roots, it’s kind
of a shock to see M’Baku in a movie at all.
Created in 1969, he originally operated under
the rather unfortunate name of “Man-Ape.”
The idea was to tie him to another jungle
animal in the same way that T’Challa drew
his powers from the panther, but deeper social
implications made him a pretty awkward supervillain
to have around.
The movie avoids a lot of that awkwardness
by just calling him M’Baku, and toning down
his costume a little while still keeping nods
to his comic book roots.
They’re small changes, but they make a whole
lot of difference.
As for where he goes from here, the movie
M’Baku does something that he never did
in the comics: he formed an alliance with
T’Challa.
Considering that Winston Duke is already listed
in the cast for Avengers: Infinity War, it’s
safe to say that this alliance is going to
last… at least for now.
Zuri
On the screen, Zuri is the spiritual leader
of Wakanda, a priest and advisor to both T’Challa
and his father, T’Chaka.
The comics tell a different story.
Zuri was one of the Black Panther’s closest
advisors, but his concerns tended to be more
on the physical side.
He was considered one of Wakanda’s strongest
warriors, and even got into a fistfight with
Thor.
Of course, since it was Thor, they became
good friends after their throwdown.
Sadly, both versions of Zuri managed to meet
their ultimate fate at the hands of a supervillain.
In the comics, though, it was during an invasion
of Wakanda by Morlun, a Spider-Man villain
who basically eats animal-themed superheroes.
That’s a pretty unlikely fate even for the
Marvel movies, but the real tragedy here is
that we lost out on Forest Whitaker and Chris
Hemsworth re-enacting Dutch and Dylan’s
epic handshake from the opening scene of Predator.
Ayo
Of all the characters in Black Panther who
deviated from their comic book roots, Ayo,
played by Florence Kasumba, was the one who
sparked a minor controversy.
In the MCU, she’s one of the Dora Milaje,
the order of potential wives-in-training who
also serve as Wakanda’s security forces,
but not much more.
In the comics, however, she became one of
Marvel’s most prominent LGBTQ characters
shortly after being introduced.
Her lover, Aneka, started out as her combat
trainer, forming a tense relationship that
developed into much more.
Unfortunately, Aneka was convicted of a crime,
and while Ayo pleaded with the reigning queen
to spare her life, it didn’t work.
Instead, Ayo broke her out and the two became
vigilantes in Wakanda known as the Midnight
Angels.
While Ayo’s orientation was only hinted
at in scenes that were ultimately cut from
the film, her story did take center stage
when Marvel launched Black Panther: World
of Wakanda, with the first arc focusing on
Ayo and Aneka’s history.
Nakia
In the film, Lupita Nyong'o plays Nakia as
T’Challa’s love interest, an ex-girlfriend
who devoted her life to working in secret
as a spy.
In the end, she steps out of the shadows to
defend Wakanda, and even steps back into her
very close personal relationship with the
Black Panther.
In the comics… not so much.
While Nakia was introduced as one of the original
Dora Milaje in 1998, she didn’t stay as
one for long.
T’Challa’s interest in the Dora Milaje
was purely ceremonial, but Nakia harbored
an infatuation with the superheroic king that
grew to the point of obsession, causing her
to attempt to murder the Black Panther’s
former girlfriend, Monica Lynne.
Nakia was dismissed from his service, and
eventually re-emerged as an enemy named Malice.
It seems unlikely that the MCU’s Nakia will
follow that path, but it’s a lot easier
to believe that something might drive a wedge
between Nakia and T’Challa to make drama
in a future film.
After all, since they’re broken up at the
start of the movie, it’s something that’s
happened to them before.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!